[Music]
[Music]
you do not few tears
[Music]
[Music]
still not used to that just drop
dropping right in here just it just hits
you
heck yeah hey Ben what's up happy Friday
Oh happy Friday to you as well to
everyone who's watching to this banger
oh my god the music everything fantastic
ladies and gentlemen we're playing the
remake of the legend of zelda links
awakening today on the stream crime
brings up an interesting point
rip community fridays 20 fries still
around but sometimes the community is it
the communities and the friends were
made along the way it's hanging out
playing a game together yeah not in the
literal sense but sometimes in the
whatever this sense is we're here with
you the community it's Friday it's
almost hot we're gonna play it's all
there again do you ever change your name
I always keep it linked so it's not
gonna matter you go long because if the
thing works that I want to do our final
name doesn't matter
right because it gets changed ah so my
my history with this is I played it the
DX version pretty much and one of my
favorite things is stealing stuff from
the store and that's something all right
so we're gonna play about the first hour
of the game here yeah you may have not
touched this at all no my copy literally
arrived 20 minutes before we start
streaming I originally yeah urgently to
borrow robbed because uh I was like hey
my copy is supposed to arrive today I
don't know when it's going to arrive
yeah usually doesn't arrive in the
morning arrives more like around lunch
so I was like ah hey Rach can I borrow
your copies yeah sure and then I was
like I gave it back to him like hey my
copy just arrived in the mail perfect
able to play this game
Ford says this game looks so good yeah
I'm really into the art style he's so
cute it's a door have you seen the
amiibo for him yeah so good-looking we
got one of the met in the office and I
was like I need that
he the idiot like the material they make
it look more plasticky to like fit the
like he's a little toy link so that's
the thing that picked pixel or pile pile
Xtreme brings up price so it is a full
$60 it's a full $60 which is kind of
weird which is a little which is a lot
we were kind of talking about that
normally I'm not the kind of person who
conflates price with like game quality
or or like time however the fact that
this is a remake of a game and it's only
around 10-ish hours I do think it's a
little weird that it's a full $60 I kind
of feel like it should have been maybe
40 40 feels like a feels like would have
been a better price it is what it is
though I I still think this game looks
amazing and you know hey I bought it so
but yeah yeah like I do think maybe
sixty feels like a little bit much and I
can understand someone who would who
would feel hesitant to buy it for a full
sixty dollars of the unfortunate thing
is that Nintendo games never really drop
and drop price so it must be yeah maybe
you can find discount somewhere
hopefully but unfortunately Nintendo
games never really price that Nintendo
prestige they like to keep up his
virtual Sasha said prices a bit much
I'll probably buy it anyway yeah you
know kind of where I am is just kind of
how it is sometimes I guess huh I was
telling myself that I wouldn't do it but
I'm sure that playing it on this dream
is gonna be it it's gonna be like I have
to go get it like I'll shoot I was gonna
hold off because there are so many other
games I have to play boy
this already feels really good I'm
really excited to play this with my
girlfriend because she has oh yeah you
can't you can't move with the d-pad oh
really I can option for it somewhere
well it's it's not a full light yeah
it's it feels weird to me though cuz I
was like oh yeah I'm moving with the
stick I know okay well it is kind of
you're right it's still a little quickie
like the movement yeah it's kind of
weird
I was gonna say I'm excited play this is
my girlfriend she she never like grew up
with Nintendo systems so she's actually
never played this Elda oh and so I'm
like actually really I'm like this is
like really cute it's only like 10 hours
is perfect I think this is a good
introduction you yeah to to 2d Zelda I
think I need to head back into town
anyway I don't know why I'm running
around I just wanted to like there's the
dungeon down that way Casper says Aloha
GameSpot in chat hello how's it going
yeah bunny I kind of agree it is weird
that there is no option for d-pad if the
game is still locked into the eight-way
I thought the game was gonna not be
locked and it was gonna have more full
360 movement but if it's still locked
but then you can't D pad it's kind of
weird I feel like you should have given
the option for people you get the key
from up in the forest so I'm trying to
recall this from memory from the whole
what 20 years ago it's been a while
should have made Pokemon look like this
I would uh I paint a Pokemon
experimenting with different styles I
imagine that would be pretty pretty
difficult I mean Pokemon like I can't
imagine how tough that workflow is
because you gotta like what remake every
Pokemon everytime they like adjust to a
new new platform but I agree I would
love to see Pokemon games get weirder
with their art style I think that'd be
cool
yes for this came out today this is my
personal copy arrived in the mail this
morning
I'm one of those people that still likes
buying physical that's game specifically
so I'll buy physical games for games I
really really like that I'm like I care
about this game I want to put it on my
shelf in general I like buying physical
copies of switch games because I think
the boxes are adorable the boxes are
really really good they're super tiny at
one point the I know at least from like
buying from certain places physical
versions were actually cheaper to some
says they should do this for a Link to
the Past that'd be cool I mean I would
like them too honestly if you were to
ask me where I'd want them to go next to
Zelda in terms of like a remake type
situation I would really like them to
just port all the 3ds games over to the
switch so link between worlds which is
fantastic and then the Ocarina of Time
and Majora's Mask remakes I put those on
and put those on switch polish them up a
little bit
arctic foxes the blurred edges are odd I
didn't even know yeah until they pointed
it out so I mean I didn't notice it
until I was watching the reporting in
the speed zone for the review stuff and
yeah there's like a weird depth of field
kind of situation going on crevasses do
a monthly video series if you can about
what new or old games he put on the
shelf I don't know if anyone would care
about that outside a crime but this
might be the kind of downside of this
cuz my eyes are kind of looking for like
I don't know it was hard to see them
you're looking around and the blurriness
yeah can you turn that off there doesn't
seem to be many there's no options here
there are no options
thanks thanks ins and though those never
agree with that and fortunately sorry
there was a comment earlier from Josh
Miller it's funny I have a friend named
Josh Miller I assume that's not D Josh
Miller but I know how this game hold up
for someone that has only
played breath of the wild oh definitely
odd job I know Josh displayed others all
the games
uh that's a good question because I
imagine there are a lot of people who
maybe breath of the wild with surfers
Elda game right like you just got a
switch I mean it's a very different game
it's not gonna have like the kind of
like the system based stuff that like
breath of the wild did where it's all
about like experimentation this is a
much more like tight you know classic
Zelda experience so gameplay wise I'd
say it's it's gonna be pretty different
however if you really just liked the the
style and the like aesthetic of Zelda I
mean I think this is this is a pretty
good time and this is a good way to try
that older Zelda style right you've also
got on the SNES emulation stuff - you've
got any regional Zelda you got - and
then you got went to the past leave the
past that's the past is also very yeah
because this is this game is kind of
came after a Link to the Past and very
much inspired by that it originally
started as them trying to port link to
the past
I think there's that old sound they got
if I'm correct I want to say that this
game originally was gonna be them trying
to port link to the path to the Game Boy
and then they made a whole game for it
instead yeah it's like you got three
different styles of Zelda right you got
like this style that kind of 2d Zelda
then you got like the 3d occurring the
series kind of styled that went all the
way up to like Skyward Sword and
Princess and then press while it's kind
of like that third new style of Zelda so
it's interesting how you probably have
people who've like only played one but
never played the other styles yeah so I
think it's kind of it's cool like I
would love to talk to somebody who's
only who's first Dalda was only breath
of the wild and then they come back to
play it yeah that that'd be an
interesting perspective for sure yeah
well Rob I don't know
exactly I think Rob has played other
Zelda's but I he's really in a breath of
the wild it's like one of his favorite
games ever made and I know he hasn't
played this game because he was saying
how
he didn't want to get spoiled on it at
all so I believe he's played I could be
wrong but I believe he's played some
other duties all those before so I don't
think this is like a completely new
experience for him but he definitely has
not played this before and I'm curious
what he thinks of it wind fish burps I
did go to the tail cave there's a key on
you find in the forest exactly so I
there's a little bit of memory still
there okay okay you got it yeah fight me
haha
get those moblins they're blue in this
month so it feels like the the combats
more of a thing that you have to kind of
like if you actually have to block and
stuff which is kind of cool
yeah I'm trying to think I mean I
definitely blocked and the other ones
but I feel like I feel like I just kind
of matched the like yeah I was kind of
just doing this the whole yeah I
definitely remember just doing that the
whole time the slow creep forward
yeah it's crime so check on link to the
past if you only ever played breath of
the wild link to the past holds up
incredibly well yeah and if you have a
Nintendo online you got that game for
free on the go which is awesome so how
do you reckon the knack game would it be
lost thanks to him no no that Rikuo I
can't believe it
inside that fairy very theme Noah theory
okay remember that also it's a weird
like compulsive thing I have to cut all
the grass oh I'm the same way
yeah see like the cleaning the opening
like that yeah remember doing that at
all
Nintendo could just make like a make a
phone game called like links lawnmower
simulator where you just cut grass and I
would light ass like a clicker game
where you just tap on the screen to cut
grass I play I play that it's free idea
for me and time though take it and run
with it look for some new hot okay yeah
yeah bunny love makes a good point where
they said if you enjoyed link to the
past to the original Zelda you'll enjoy
this if you haven't played those check
those out first and then you can try
them a lot cheaper than then paying $60
for this so if you're like not sure if
you are yeah don't worry that's just uh
let's just for us you know no one else
can our headphone cables acting up but
yeah if you are interested in this game
but not sure if you'd like the the the
way it plays or you know like you've
never played it soul begin like this and
you have online you can try link to the
past for for free basically yeah free -
obviously your online subscription and
then if you like it then you can
consider getting this game I'm gonna try
and try and get our thing working do it
it feels good to kind of you're playing
is I'll game like this again because
it's it's been a long time yeah
it really has I wonder okay I'm smart
enough to do the puzzle when I come back
I'm gonna try to I'm gonna try it
hey Terry happy weekend to you as well
yeah that's Friday blue Drago says
Oracle seasons should receive a reboot I
agree I think we're gonna I was talking
about that with I want to say Kali and
Jake earlier this week that yeah they
should do a remake of Oracle of Seasons
and Oracle of Ages spirit those games
are really cool spear tracks
give me more conductor link spirit
tracks is I'm very 50/50 on that game
I think the game it itself is a little I
don't know it doesn't grab me quite as
much as other Zelda games that said
conductor link is incredibly good yes
and I think that game also has the best
Zelda in any legend zelda game I'm not
strong enough
like from a character perspective I
think spirit tracks Helda is the best
zelda they're like what if we made a
Zelda game about a train and it was
really rad oh also that that's that
train theme yeah ooh the main theme for
spirit tracks banger I like picking that
one in a smash alot I totally forgot the
area 51
no God did you see that that news thing
the gift was gone oh yeah with the guys
running with the Naruto run the
background props to back to that kid
Yeah right what a legend so when people
like that's really all I needed out of
it it's like I don't really care about
anything else about this raid thing like
I saw that and I was like that's it
that's all
that's all I really wanted we've made it
we've made it it's all hit that needed
to happen I want this game but it's
currently too expensive for me
understand that's fair and it's a lot
those one of the first things we talked
about it it seems like a like I I'll buy
it because I can but it's I don't
believe anyone he's like match there's a
little too much for me hopefully you can
find a discount at some point
politically said I can that's always
tricky with Nintendo games there's
there's something something that I'm
Sasha it says Raph the wild was the
first and only Zelda game I've played he
considered all the praise I've heard
about Ocarina of Time I really wish they
remastered it for the switch like this
one yeah I mean there's the 3ds remaster
which is very good but I agree I think
they should put that version on the
switch
hmm you're smoking crack if you think
spear cracks is the best zelda I think
we said it was the best zelda no it's
not the best you just said you like to
like it I'd like to see it come back oh
I have to pull on this inventories thing
I think I need to find a way how do i
how I used on him I want to I want to
mess up that that raccoons smell ability
I know that so what you have to do
what's the puzzle for this you have to
like mess them up so I think I have to
use the mushroom because it has a strong
smell and the smell stuff messes him up
but I need to like that's what I have to
do I get like like a same - it's been a
long time so if there's something I
don't remember that someone is like ah
you idiot it's supposed to be this tell
me because 20 years is a long time to
not do this bunny says the which turns
it into powder only from the witch
that's what it was Thank You bunny yeah
yeah yeah I think the witch is out over
here yeah you have the running thing yet
that I've seen that animation it's so
good mmm
this this looks like it's it looks like
a place where which would hang out there
we go
it has the sleepy toadstool it does
there we go now we're cooking
literally Daniels was thinking to get in
this game since the switch light is out
today and I don't already have one yeah
as anyone pick up the switch lights
today I don't know if I don't the switch
light is for me I don't know if it's for
me either so I might still still
debating on it but what what might
happen is my told me my girlfriend how
switches however she never uses hers
whatever and anytime she does play
switch we're always playing together
co-op on the TV on my switch so we were
thinking about maybe trading it in and
just picking up a switch light just to
have one but it's also like well would
we still use it I don't know so I'm kind
of beating on it yeah that's but like a
good way to do it we got one in the
office that a Peter Browns been been
messing with so look forward to review
that soon but it's really cute it's
super small it's very light I like the
color we've got that that Miku blue it
is less small than I thought it's later
though yeah when you pick it up in
you're like wow this is so light big
houses let me have your girlfriend
switch yeah yeah crime says I don't
think open the switch lights green no
that's the thing is this which light is
like very much designed around playing
by yourself like you're definitely not
gonna be playing co-op it doesn't even
have a kickstand like so the whole thing
in the in like that reveal trailer where
they go up to like the rooftop party and
they're like put the switch down and
they hand pass all the joy Khan
controllers yeah it's really just meant
to be a portable handheld for for one
person switch light doesn't switch it
doesn't have you know switch at all the
fact that they're still calling in a
switch bothers me low-key is it like a
the the 2d s like
well I mean they at least called it like
it like a 2d s like ah it's not 3d
anymore I guess so what they call it not
switched but not switched
find something else different branding
that the 3d no switch my life is what
we're doing cuz if you take the T out of
light and it's it's like mine the switch
lie
the switch line oh there's the key bunny
says go back to calling it the NX Mego
uh come talk to me not Kippur Gabor Oh
tell me the thing go now the wind fish
is waiting hoot now fortunes just called
the new Game Boy there you go oh the
gameboy switch that Gameboy switch that
makes sense cuz like I know when I think
a game where I think of being only
portable we don't need to be up here
this is can we go back down let's just
go straight to the dungeon yeah people
who don't know much about Link's
Awakening will start to notice like the
chain chomps and you've got not not
Mario Mario there's a reason for that
there's there's a reason for all these
weird funny I like this one the baton
switch
oh man that's a good one spicy oh I love
it
that's so good
Brendan wants to know you guys flip my
Monster Hunter I know Brandon always
likes for that Monster Hunter
um yeah I think you've been playing a
little bit more than me I have there's
so many games out that I have for the
moment moved on but if I want to get
back to Monster Hunter hard amis kind of
thinking I'm just gonna maybe like get
back to it on PC when it comes out next
year I mean there's so many other games
but there's so many games right now that
I've been like trying to play for both
work and just plant for like Fonzie's
that unfortunately I haven't been able
to give monster hundred the do I want
it's it's a bummer because when world
originally came out it was like the
perfect time nothing else was out you
had a whole I had a whole like month out
half where I could just play Monster
Hunter it was great
and this remake or the expansion came
out
just in the middle of everything else
and some real real bummer yeah I need to
finish firebombs one that I'm the only
done like three battles I'm pretty sure
that by the time I actually get around
to to doing Fire Emblem all that deal
sees you had the the guide leaked like
what the other content is for the rest
of the season pass oh I'm probably gonna
like oh man that's that's good yeah I'm
probably gonna be like seven time I'll
be like man time to finally get back to
the farm bland will be like DLCs out
dang it no that's fine cuz you just get
the full experience okay so they're
adding extra units see if anything about
that way I'll just wait but I should
still play it also apparently there's
like out like I'm raid called like a
this mode which has gotten me the most
excited that's all pretty hardcore
well yeah little [ __ ] over there yeah
so cute but the thing about abyss mode
is I don't think we know what it is and
in my mind I automatically think of like
abyss mode and blazblue okay she's just
like imagine like a survival mode for a
strategy game we're like you level up
and get items and stuff alright so I'm
gonna try to do this I'm saying here's
five is really hard that are stuck gonna
act - I just beat gears five uh earlier
on Tuesday I like that game that games
really surprised me actually no that's
still heart piece cuz that's a lot of
money
[Music]
Alexes I don't get why there's a Chain
Chomp that's kind of this whole games
like aesthetic is kind of a weird
mismatch of other I could tell you the
reason for it but wow we don't want to
we don't want to spoil the reason for it
the game actually does kind of give you
a reason why it's all there but
basically this game kind of is a little
more playful than other Zelda games and
has a ton of hey trying to steal from
him yeah it's it's different it's the
the fact that he's got the delay makes
me think that you still can I wonder if
it's like uh you try it real you try
real hard because before you just you
just have to circle around them a whole
bunch look look over here since I think
it's like a delayed timing thing now hmm
or maybe you can't if they took that out
of this game I swear stop right there
criminal scum went allow that con uh
wait a minute
No
oh I don't think it's possible I'm gonna
try one more kind of taking it out I
don't know if it's because like you the
spots been crying stuck on the matriarch
and gears yeah that's a tough fight that
took me a couple tries that was a that
was a tough one look up look more up
over here
confirmed cannot damn dude no he was
looking up I can't believe I think they
took it out we gotta like Tim okay I'm
done yeah your dad you're done that was
one of my favorite things because it
changes your file name to thief and no
one talks to you and you why would that
not be there well seems like you can't
do a name one I'm sorry how dare you yep
is so it's not just a a Japanese thing
where Fox's say yet because in persona 4
there's a Fox and it also says yet yet
you do more than just
[Music]
it's kind of cool to hear it like with a
voice not yet I'm real bust up about
that I said he can like like he follows
you around to kind of make you think you
can do it unless is just harder bummer
yeah enough time in this village dungeon
sounds fun yeah this musics so good and
yeah the music is I was like weird like
I'm start like half we're calling like
what things looked like like as I'm
walking away I love it and I'm sorry I
was worried that I wouldn't like how
shiny everything is like it looks like
it's part of a plastic play set I'm into
it I'm into it like this like the the
top head overview makes it look like
it's a 3d like diorama like a model yeah
we're looking at a Bhushan Ryu cat says
they're loving the heck out of untitled
goose game that was the other one we
were gonna back to say yeah it was the
other one
but Robin and Peter did a did a little
let's play you can go check out I
believe right now you should definitely
check it out computer so definitely do
that because that is very good run Peter
to my favorite people and I get really
excited whenever they're actually I know
it's been a while they both been so busy
they they haven't had to do that in a
while so very very happy they got to do
that
hmm have already two guys get in the
game and did you get they link tackle
ability so we just started yeah this is
just the beginning yeah we we were not
one of the people that got early copies
in the office so this is my copy that
arrived today in the mail started first
time on the stream so we're very early
just recalling how to do everything from
memory memory from back when I played DX
oh I think I might have played a
friend's copy of the original and then I
I was like oh that games on the the its
there's a DX version now and I needed to
get it for myself so I can actually play
and then I did and it was good we dived
in the dungeon creator I I watched some
people do it but not too much myself
that's kind of interesting I'm done in
creative stuff it's it's kind of kind of
basic ish but I mean it's a cool idea
though
yeah I mean I've heard some people kind
of say it doesn't live up to maybe like
the potential that it could I think the
idea of a like infinite dungeons knows
all the game but like almost uh like a
Mario maker but riselle the dungeons
like like I want I want it to go that
far right like make give me like maybe
that's bull like a prototype for that
kind of like messing with the idea yeah
cuz I think that would be really cool
like a full-on proper like beat the
Zelda dungeon it's also weird to not
have the screen transitions joy
like when you walk across like a the
area that's too big whatever man yeah I
really would not mind if they just took
this art salad and then made Oracle
pages and seasons that would be I'd
actually be really into that I've done
it it is a lot faster without the
transitions but part of me misses that
like that's sort of like Mega Man kind
of like yeah or believe and then it and
then it freezes and moves yeah I could
just say I miss the Zelda thing but it's
an aesthetic thing for sure but yeah
it's a lot faster a little bit it's kind
of funny how like that was clearly just
like a limitation of the hardware but it
being a thing it ended up being just
like an aesthetic thing that you're like
grow attached to yeah it's not a deal
breaker or anything no how dare they
remove those transitions this is
literally unplayable I need to be
careful I actually look out for what I'm
doing here
slipping up oh no I have to deal with
that now we don't have to deal with that
perfect I knew it was there the whole
time bye
I don't think I have the key for this
these art styles work well for lower and
Hardware agreed however if the King does
kind of have a little frame drops which
is I think is actually tied to those old
transitions I was talking to Peter about
it he's like yeah that's the thing he
also noticed because it's not like when
you're walking through the overworld
it's not over everything it's right it's
just in certain spots yeah so it's a
little weird crime scenes on dice right
they're just like Oh move the square
block after I did it that was definitely
not in the original game those little
hints their eyes I'm so cute yeah I
gotta say that art style that makes me
feel bad for killing them you look more
angry they look more cute no I like that
I don't know you put it a hint thing in
there no I probably can't read until
goombahs with her there's Satsuki
kiryuin eyebrows my favorite enemy in
this whole game is there a limit size to
the dungeon building I have no idea what
the I only saw like the the challenge
mode we had to kind of like build out or
like like there's like there's a
progression to it that you unlock more
parts yeah I couldn't personally tell
you what the limitations that are oh man
I wonder what we're gonna get in here
[Music]
looks like a regal feather though and
that makes me happy yeah you know it's
also nice about this version of the game
is it's way easier to swap items and
stuff when Jake and Evan were trying to
capture footage at the same time of both
versions to do like a comparison Evan we
had the original version and he would
always be like they would try and be
playing at the same time and like match
each other's movements and then would
always get delayed though because did
those we had to like do more work in
menus to like switch items around there
there are a lot of items that just get
used now and you don't have to equip
them to use them which is nice whoo
Arnold in the chat says the hints for
the original okay it's been it's been
forever I also never beat this game I
played a little bit of it but I never I
never beat it or anything like that
I mean the hits were in the original but
I mean like it's it's weird that they'd
have it set up in a way that's like oh
no I have to fight these Turtles and
then by the time you struggle through
the turtles and they're dead you get the
hint on how to beat the turtles oh sure
oh he did that to himself how
embarrassing Oh
Amaury says they just did they were able
to steal something and the salesman
called them a thief shoot okay probably
the dungeon I'll go back and do it maybe
just can't do the heartbeat maybe
what did you steal yeah what'd you steal
it's blocking the whole time you can't
make it across yeah nice so that's just
to go back to the Link's Awakening and
maybe I'll give you anything special
breath in the wild ooh I don't I don't
think we've tried it I think we tried it
I don't I haven't heard of then retro
actively adding anything Zelda amiibos
unlock special dungeon pieces for the
dungeon maker though for this this is
grim
no hello yes see you later
I don't have this boskie fairly certain
yeah the nightmare it's all there when
you when you think about it there's
something that I missed in here just
trick the yeah check the map hmm
see yes quite there are a lot of things
I didn't open yes
take me back no don't take me back I'm
gonna walk i'ma walk my own way there we
go
that's just this though all right yeah
you're right I don't need to show off
that I can hit things on time yeah where
do you need to go so there's a chest
that's up that way that I need to get
there's also BOM wall over here but I
don't have bombs yet so we've got this
thing over here we've got this one down
here so you got that chest up there give
a regular carry no I can jump across
there now yeah yeah yeah it's got a
parole those those new things you get
together make that jump across the way
but yeah I need you to have a key so
yeah perfect
just like I planned it that's gotta be a
dudududu that is he's a nightmare
whoo all right probably pick up heart
before I head in there though
I can't go here yet
[Music]
hmm so I probably shouldn't have picked
up the the hearts downstairs I don't
think they come back no if they do
perfect what now we're good to go
I can't embarrass myself on this boss
David says they're playing the nests
it's all live right now hmm so that's
one that like I paid but I couldn't get
into it's it's very very open-ended yeah
it's a cool ideas that game is very
tricky to play without I mean it sort of
hints
it's a hamburger you can't lie to me
that's a weird-ass hamburger right I
mean what was all set up now it's just a
bunch of hamburger so uh mari says they
stole a shovel okay but I think you guys
need to go further in the game to be
able to get away with stealing so maybe
we just couldn't do at the very
beginning I wouldn't be surprised I'll
try it with the shovel like twice
[Music]
frightening creature stop nice it up
you're bored forgot to breathe for a
second
[Music]
give me that
crimson scents nests on senescence which
do you think GameCube can come to the
nests online I would I would love for
them to put gamecube gamecube games on
the on the sweet big same at full moon
cello
I really wish Luigi's Mansion one was on
I wanted to replay Luigi's Mansion one
but I rather play like the GameCube
version then the I don't want to find 3s
I wanna play my TV basically so I kind
of wish I wish I could play that easily
swamp swamp get out of my swamp the
legal emulation of that is fantastic you
can play it like in 4k oh and it runs
very well be allowed to say that legal
emulation illegal I'm gonna like if you
if you've got your discs and you guys
like the put it all in into your into
your dolphin don't support illegal
emulation now of course not it's an
instrument of the sirens
seven others in the set the power to
wake the wind fish wind wake wake wind
oh wind instruments hello next coal is
north and the swamp what is it you you
should itch that foot look away back up
the town head over the swamp shoot we've
only got like it's only doing 20 20 more
minutes yeah we only got 20 more minutes
we're gone we're going for like an hour
so just say you're employed Zelda all
day
hey man of you Ani that's cool I gotta
go edit some stuff after but I am you
just want to sit here all day and play
Zelda I do a whole a whole playthrough
the mob 'let's came to the village Shan
now I like the texture shaking yeah I
threw the kid and what's the house did
something - oh no whoa it's a bad scene
tamari with that was a high I wish
Nintendo would remake Paper Mario and
the thousand-year door dude that said
good good Paper Mario game so I uh I
really wish that they would bring those
games back to the house so Paper Mario
games are very good I've never played
them all but I've dabbled with some of
them my brother he's like obsessed with
them I know that everyone really doesn't
like the more recent Paper Mario because
because they're very different and not
as good oh yeah I've always kind of
wanted to try one but I never got around
to it and I feel bad thousand-year door
is apparently like the one to play is
what I have heard
accessories would be nice mm-hmm all
right I'm gonna try to steal a shovel
and see if it happens if it doesn't
happen that's fine just give it a couple
of tries not not get too hung up on it
[Music]
this music is stressing me out and he
have it if you think of a genre at link
has not been in fYI cross-training
councils first-person shooter
Battle Royale right for it 100 links 100
links drop on to a high roll a silly
island yeah maybe it is like later on
cuz even even when he's looking the
other way
I'm worried says hey don't worry guys
we're still the shovel eventually oh
yeah maybe maybe and we can do it later
I'm glad to hear that it is else was
able to do it is possible ford says if
anyone hasn't played eternal darkness
and magically still has gamecube
definitely check it out good for
Halloween season darkness is so good and
I there's been no other like scary game
like it since then I've been I've been
want to make a list of scary games and
movies and stuff to watch for for a
spooky spooky time Susan just come in
fast approaching it's true so that's a
good one it really is almost October
that's crazy also so not always eternal
darkness really gonna play the sava game
keep it for some of the that games like
bits to work you should play it on a CRT
yeah yeah yeah actually yeah yes you
kind of need to play on a CRT for that
games bits to work real well I think I
was like it so far
Rick I'm I'm having a great time it's
ends feeling it it's it's kind of
interesting because like I didn't like
get a chance to play it I didn't we play
the old one originally some kind of like
when I remember from memory for stuff
you need to get away from this music it
is it's freaking me out
yeah it's like causing me an anxiety
attack who is that not about the the
minigames you know what's it's like
actually like causing my anxiety to
spike it's pretty bad which one you
going for I wanted the bigger one but
this is fine I just want to see the
smile that like does oh that's the
content that's adorable need just like
you it's small but plenty of fight oh
that's really good got a dream bigger
than that uh oh I got I made my money
back
and you got a hard piece just for doing
it for catching the best fish in the
pond
no I didn't I I wanted to back out nah
man you gotta catch that fish now I
guess so
alright let's let this sink a bit let's
get that that big guy
look at that you want to bite that you
know you do come on cut yep oh come on
yeah you're mine now
bonnie is he is he knows that he's close
to the top of the water
come on real big fish I saw a crime I
saw it I'm here for those sky references
I'm picking up what you pick it up pick
it up pick it up I was gonna wait to
dimension to TV until after you caught
it cuz no this is it's just not meant to
be and that's okay bummer
Bob Genesis this is a man I'm a fighter
Monster Hunter mana we really do have a
brand don't we do it's it's got a strong
strong brand stank to it you know what
we got we got ten minutes that sounds
like enough time to try to get the
yoshito do it you've got enough money to
maybe yeah
I'm ready - I'm ready to mess it up so
all of my time spent playing Yaga's
games should be a good amount of
practice for this bhushan yes uh it's
more funny I don't I don't know if I
necessarily hate it I think it's just
funny whenever people mistake us for a
game stop it happens people say it a lot
by accident
there were people when I first applied
for it when I got this job I said like
yeah I'm moving to California to go work
for GameSpot and everyone's like Oh for
like retail that's weird and I was like
second biggest store I was like not
retail third time's the charm
it's more funny but uh yeah I know
whatever
yes yeah I'll get that second try dang
I'm pretty stoked about that you know
what let's let's go for the heart piece
cuz that's that's over there - yeah
that's fine that's okay
don't don't stress that anyone played
the n64 Legend of Zelda which one
nightlife Joker sir there are few Helios
oh there was a bottle in the water we
missed the pond secret secret bottles
message I forgot you can't tap it every
time we need two other ones anyone get
that shield Bell I think we have already
got you but that's the buzz - Hylian
Shield oh you want a good shield man now
you don't need to keep doing this oh you
got 10 minutes well we'll move on yeah
yeah I actually thought that the ocean
always going to take a little bit longer
than that no she can't count how many
games you've seen him in now the real
just breaking the fourth wall that wall
doesn't exist anymore no it's gone obeah
ocarina is great Oh God
majora's mask might be one of my my
favorite so how do you get this music to
stop
the one up north with two doors let's do
it but no justice a shame just kidding
I'll trade you the Yoshi doll for your
baby Amy babies
[Music]
I bet I bet I know where we take this
ribbon I'm sorry for the music again
it's okay I just got the ribbon I need
it yeah let's do it
[Laughter]
like this is where the the thing ends
leave just one of the dog food juicy
beef ah elbow it's a good bow and the
lavender town feels yeah scene yeah same
energy try to make our way let's do the
thing I don't know if we'll actually
make it in time
what say we didn't try hit me I don't
know if I like that it does the pickup
every time but I say I know that I've
got it jump on jump it out fall in the
hole - yeah you can even jump - yeah BAM
harpy's perfect
how do you describe the art style like
uh it's like a little toy toy toy kind
of diorama model looka little clay ish
not really quick though like um a
different state like a plastic toy yeah
plastic plastic toy diorama this music
is still playing ah the combat trials
okay here for it
Amaury says is the best dream I've seen
so far great job you guys give it the
good work thank you very much they're
actually gonna be closing the stream
down in in a few minutes here we wanted
to only go for an hour because it is a
this isn't a terribly long game so I
don't think we wanted to really like
show too much I think an hour is a good
amount of Zelda to to show off it's
gonna do the run and then you get them
yeah
do it dude oh I got it I got hang out
over here BAM nice all right we're
getting it getting the flow back in do
again dude over here I dare you oh oh
dude double no I gotta make all these
boss fights really close like calls
that's that's just how it works
we're building it up nice I want to see
I planned it but I definitely didn't
Eric Jones I agree I would love an
Oracle of Ages slash seasons remake on
this engine please make that Nintendo
I'm so good
Wow Bow Wow fearsome beast dude little
bow-wow is as a Stan got him I remember
this too I for the longest time I
thought that change humps are called
bow-wows because of this game cirque
Ronson is game worth the buy well we
gave it a Peter Brown gave it an 8 out
of 10 which is a great yeah and I am you
know we've only played an hour here so
far but I'm pretty into it so I I think
if you are into this kind of kind of
game if you like Zelda and if you have
fond memories of this or you just want
to try it out I think it's it's
definitely worth picking up it is $60
which we were kind of say in the feels
feels like a lot for a remake but so
maybe if you're both at change home just
ate that man so if that feels like a
little high of a price for you maybe try
and wait for it to drop a little bit
although Nintendo games tend to not drop
in price but you can kind of be of a
bummer but I would say this is
definitely worth playing at some point
this
you pick up interesting stuff huh I know
better I know who you are
mmm I trust him well I think this is
we're gonna call it oh man
but the cheese shall be eaten all the
crow that's horrifying
man I love it okay yeah that's that's
fine this hmm I can't dig him
Temari said that Resident Evil remake
was also 60 that's true yeah I mean I
think it's just gonna come down to your
personal personal preference and and how
you feel about it so there's no wrong
answers it's it's whatever you feel in
your heart of hearts
anyway that is legend of zelda links
awakening by the way if you go to the I
just just for fun quickly go to the
homescreen for a sec I like how it says
links awake when you want to go it yeah
just as links awake and I think that's
really funny
hey everyone in the links awake links
away go get them anyway and point that
out
thanks for watching everybody yeah this
has been a really fun time I really like
this game and I can't wait to play it
this weekend if you are interested in
more fantastic GameSpot content then Oh
point do we got a lot for you we got a
really cool conversation that Peter
Kelly it's more did on deaf stranding
that's gonna go up tomorrow so check
that out it's a really good conversation
if you like awesome videos that kind of
breakdown the real life inspirations in
pop culture and movies and TV shows then
we got a show for you it's called true
fiction that are our friends on our
original programming team have been hard
at work on for it feels like ever yes it
is hosted by Kurt who has been working
here since I want to say may and he's
been only working on this so he's been
here for like six months and this is
his first lighted this is mr. video
exactly so I know he's been working real
hard on that along with everyone else
there so please give that a watch it
premieres at GameSpot universe on Sunday
so you can go check it out
on gamespot universe to youtube or you
can go to dance Viacom yeah that that
[ __ ] is really cool and I highly
recommend highly recommend it so I
please go check that out if that's
interesting
other than that we'll see you guys on
Monday for another GameSpot livestream I
know the after but it's not working
- see ya the thing for some reason
doesn't work I have to him anyone
alright well here we are it's outdoors
ruined goodbye
[Music]